good morning john you are not eating a
credit card's worth of microplastics a
week now you might not have been worried
about that but a lot of people are and
that makes sense because a lot of very
credible news organizations have run
stories saying that you are eating a
credit card's worth of microplastics
every week the fact that this definitely
untrue statement was spread in so many
legitimate news organizations has been
quite annoying to me but it's also been
something of a curiosity to me like
these places do fact check they don't
just publish whatever comes across their
desk itself knowing that it is almost
always better to lean into curiosity
than frustration i did that and what i
found is remarkable this was an 11 step
process step one the world wildlife fund
is worried about plastics and they
should be there are too many way too
many single-use plastics and we need to
stop this so step two the wwf
commissioned a study from the university
of newcastle to do a literature review
basically look at a bunch of different
studies that measured how plastics might
enter people and then add all of those
sources up every study that they
reviewed had a different range they
added all those ranges up and they came
to their own range of 0.1 grams to 5
grams of plastic ingested every week and
this isn't useful data to the average
person it's just too imprecise it's like
saying that the average person eats
between one pound and 50 pounds of food
per day the wwf then did a normal thing
they used the study they commissioned to
create a talking point people could be
consuming five grams of microplastics
per week this is not a lie but it's kind
of a misrepresentation it's kind of
misleading all this happened in 2019 and
none of it reached very far because
headlines that said you could be eating
a credit card of plastic per week is
like well i could be eating a thousand
spiders per night tell me when you're
sure no one wrote that people definitely
were eating a credit card's worth of
plastic per week until 2022 why step
number four scientists at the medical
university of vienna were among those
who were misled they took the upper
bound of the estimate the five grams and
used it as just a background stat in the
introduction to their pain when they did
that they removed the context of the
lower bound they didn't say 0.1 grams 25
grams they just said five grams it
didn't have anything to do with their
methodology or what they were studying
it was just a background stat and that's
not really what people paid the most
attention to when they're doing peer
review so step six peer review didn't
catch it step number seven that
publication then got run through the
university pr team which is tasked with
presenting research in ways that might
be interesting to the average person and
to the press and unsurprisingly the very
first sentence in that press release was
five grams of plastic particles on
average entered the human
gastrointestinal tract per person per
week because indeed if that were true it
would be a very interesting statistic so
you're going to put it at the beginning
of your press release so now we have a
press release of a peer-reviewed paper
that says that people on average eat a
credit card's worth of plastic every
week step number eight less than a week
later gut news.com had found that press
release and published a headline
containing the claim step number nine
that article spread fast enough that the
very next day the new york post
published an article with the claim in
the headlines step number 10 legitimate
news outlets saw the new york post
article and they were like well we can't
just publish that because the new york
post lies for a living but we will do a
fact check and they did and they found a
peer-reviewed paper that contained the
claim peer-reviewed article plus a
really great headline that's going to be
good enough for them step number 11 it
was a really good headline so lots of
people clicked on it and lots of people
shared it meaning it wasn't just
published it spread when i first saw
this headline i was super lucky because
it was in the new york post and i know
to be skeptical of the new york post but
if you saw it first at usa today or abc
news or nautilus all totally legitimate
news organizations and if you're like
primed by this world to believe that
everything is as bad as could possibly
be i totally understand not being
skeptical of that headline it is kind of
wild to me how many steps and how many
mistakes were made along the way in
order for this false fact to get
published in mainstream news outlets
every person in their own way is trying
to make sense of the world and we would
like the sense that we make of the world
to be based on reality even though we've
built up many systems for doing that as
individuals and as a society our own
very normal biases and the realities of
what it takes to capture people's
attention these days makes sense-making
a monster of a challenge john i'll see
you on tuesday